bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo alors comme c'est l'été
j'ai décidé de vous parler d'une petite
expérience que vous pouvez faire à
l'extérieur c'est faire des bulles de
savon géantes est donc aujourd'hui on va
voir les trois éléments essentiels qui
sont le liquide l'instrument et puis
bien sûr la technique
alors avant de commencer juste un tout
petit peu de théorie qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une bulle de savon et ben en fait
déjà la dénomination bulles de savon
elle est un peu impropre puisque on
devrait plutôt appeler ça une bulle
d'eau tiers que une bulle en fait c'est
une mince pellicule d'eau qui est très
très fine ça fait à peu près 100
nanomètres et donc il ya une forme
sphérique
normalement les molécules d'eau elles
n'ont pas du tout envie de se laisser
est allé en un film comme ça elles n'ont
qu'une envie c'est plutôt de se
regrouper ensemble
la raison en fait c'est qu'elle n'aime
pas l'air et donc le rôle du savon là
dedans c'est justement de se mettre à
l'interface entre l'eau et l'air donc de
chaque côté du film est en quelque sorte
de jouer le rôle d'intermédiaire et de
stabiliser le film d'eau d'ailleurs si
vous voulez entendre parler de phénomène
qui soit un petit peu similaire je vous
recommande d'aller voir ma vidéo sur le
pastis alors passons maintenant à la
réalisation pratique le truc le plus
important pour faire des bulles de savon
géantes c'est évidemment le liquide que
vous allez utiliser donc le liquide à
bulles on va le faire nous-mêmes et pour
ça il vous faut trois ingrédients le
premier ingrédient c'est évidemment
doubl'ô je vous ai dit une bulle c'est
avant tout de l'eau le deuxième gradient
c'est du liquide vaisselle et le
troisième ingrédient c'est un
épaississant le rôle de l'épée 600 en
fait ça va être de rendre les bulles
plus solide et plus stable ce qui va
nous permettre de faire des bulles
géantes dans cette affaire le choix du
liquide vaisselle en fait est
primordiale et tout dépend de la marque
il se trouve qu'il ya des marques qui
fonctionne et docks qui ne fonctionne
pas du tout alors les marques qui sont
connus pour très bien marché les voici
donc ces down ferry joy yes et drift
si vous habitez en france ses marques
elle vous dit peut-être pas grand-chose
et en fait elles sont assez difficiles à
trouver
on les trouve surtout soit dans les
autres pays d'europe soit en amérique du
nord
heureusement il se trouve que sur amazon
on peut en trouver certaines notamment
le train
en moi pour ma part j'utilise le produit
qui s'appelle down potes à une panne qui
en fait un liquide pour les
professionnels de la restauration
l'autre ingrédient essentiel je vous ai
dit c'est un épaississant comme
épaississant vous pouvez utiliser par
exemple du sucre en action samedi j'aime
pas trop parce que ça marche pas hyper
bien qu'en plus du coup c'est un peu
dégueulasse impôts paulhan vous pouvez
aussi utiliser de la glycérine ça ne
marche pas mal on en trouve notamment en
pharmacie est alors moi j'utilise de
plus pas longtemps un truc absolument
génial que j'ai découvert qui s'appelle
le djelloul en fait le jello il s'agit
au départ d'un produit qui est destiné
aux vétérinaires
c'est un super lubrifiants et le but se
base c'est de les aider quand ils font
l'accouchement des animaux peine blague
et il se trouve que le djelloul il va
marcher aussi super bien pour épaissir
vos bulles et alors c'est quelque chose
qui est très très concentré parce
qu'avec une bouteille comme ça qui fait
pas 300 grammes comme à chaque fois pour
faire 10 litres de liquide
on en met que quelques grammes vous
pouvez tenir toute notre vie avec juste
une seule bouteille de jénine alors le
job on le trouve sur amazon et si j'en
crois les commentaires des clients et
des produits qui sont proposés avec en
fait c'est pas vraiment des vétérinaires
qu'ils achètent mais c'est plutôt d'un
côté ceux qui comme moi veulent faire
des bulles de savon géantes et puis de
l'autre des gens qui ont besoin d'un
super super lubrifiants une petite note
pour ceux qui auraient accès à un labo
de chimie en fait le principal
ingrédient du jay loops et du pe du poly
oxyde d'éthylène hausse est un polymère
mais je pense qu'il doit être d'un poids
moléculaire assez élevé et donc c'est ça
qui donne la propriété des festi semant
des bulles donc si vous avez du perreux
vous pouvez utiliser directement du pays
alors les proportions dans tout ça
qu'est ce que c'est ma vous prenez
environ 250 millilitres de produit
vaisselle 1 ou 2 g de djelloul et vous
diluez tout ça dans 5 à 10 litres ne
vous voyez qu'avec ça vous pouvez faire
à peu près 10 litres de liquide par la
deuxième chose a absolument pas à
négliger c'est l'instrument que vous
allez utiliser pour former les bulles
alors pour ça il va vous falloir
essentiellement des baguettes de bois et
de la corde alors les spécialistes
recommandent de prendre de la corde en
coton relativement épaisse
il faut penser qu'en fait cette corde
elle va servir à contenir le liquide
c'est-à-dire que quand votre bulle va se
former elle va avoir besoin de liquide
et donc elle va le cuisez dans la corde
voudrait beaucoup de mal à faire des
bulles géantes par exemple avec un fil
de fer est donc idéalement une corde en
coton quelques millimètres d'épaisseur
c'est quelque chose qui a à peu près la
texture des lacets ce moulin et vous
êtes h et deux cordes ensemble alors il
faut qu'il y en ait une qui soit deux
fois plus longue que l'autre et que
celle qui est plus longue
vous la lester avec un petit anneau
métallique et donc comme ça vous obtenez
une structure qui va joliment former
votre film de salon et permettre aux
bulles de se gonfler à moi j'ai attaché
les cordes ensemble et puis ensuite j'ai
relié les cordes avec un tout petit bout
de ficelle à un petit trou que j'ai
percé dans mes baguettes
alors qu'au début soyez pas forcément
trop gourmand avec la longueur des
cordes
vous pouvez obtenir un résultat qui est
vraiment très très chouette avec des
cordes qui sont pas si longue
juste pour vous donner une idée dans les
vidéos que je vous montre la plus grande
corde que j'utilise en fait l'accord dû
au fait 60 cm et celle d'ubs a fait un
médecin donc c'est grand mais c'est pas
non plus monstrueux
alors sur la technique tout d'abord
sachez que vos bulles seront quand même
beaucoup plus stable si vous choisissez
un jour qui est relativement humide en
tout cas pas trop sec pas trop chaud
parce que sinon et bien l'évaporation
provoque la destruction de la bulle et
d'ailleurs si vous essayez de faire ça
un jour qui est un petit peu plus sec
n'hésitez pas à mettre plus d'eau dans
votre saut croyez pas que c'est parce
que vous mettez plus de liquide
vaisselle que ça va mieux marché des
fois il faut mettre plus d'eau alors
ensuite sur la technique est bien le
principe est simple vous trempez vos
baguettes et votre corde dans le seau et
voulait relever en maintenant les
baguettes serré ensuite vous ouvrez les
baguettes donc les cordes se séparent et
permettent de former le film de savon
hélas il ya un petit peu de vent et ben
vous laisser le vent gonfler la bulle
sinon vous pouvez marcher ou essayer de
faire quelques mouvements avec vos bras
et une fois que la bulle et formez vous
rapprocher les baguettes pour clore la
bulle si vous faites pas il ya toutes
les chances que le film éclate et que
vous perdiez votre bulle
vous allez voir la technique bien assez
vite un même les enfants peuvent y
arriver très très bien un petit détail
quand même si vous faites avec des
enfants il faut que la corde et le
liquide reste bien propre donc il faut
absolument éviter de faire traîner
l'accord par terre et ensuite de l'arbed
fonction voilà et vous allez voir
qu'avec un petit peu d'entraînement et
bien vous aussi vous allez pouvoir
former des bulles géantes
alors ce qui m'intéresserait c'est que
en commentaire vous me partager vos
expériences notamment peut-être vos
recettes si jamais vous avez réussi à
trouver le produit vaisselle qui va bien
ou pas et vous me disiez comment ça se
passe
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo c'était
probablement la dernière avant les
vacances d'été
vous retrouverez donc en septembre d'ici
là n'hésitez pas comme d'habitude à
partager cette vidéo pour m'aider à
faire connaître la chaîne vous pouvez
aussi me soutenir sur tipi c'est nouveau
et vous pouvez me retrouver sur facebook
sur twitter sur mon blog qui s'appelle
science étonnante
voilà merci et à bientôt